[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to Hannity and welcome all
of you what a great proud We Have
Tonight great to see you all back with
our live audience tonight
panicked in New York City over the
influx of the illegal immigrants and now
an overflow Public Schools open today in
New York City and this new
um inundation of of children in the
public school system in New York it is
way out of control they had no idea how
to handle it nobody knew it was in
charge and many of these children by the
way do not speak English putting massive
stress on what is an already failing
school system wow great job mayor Adams
okay anyway
I agree Curtis Lee has a lot to say
he'll be here tonight the Democrats
sanctuary City he's now worried that
so-called Asylum Seekers are going to
destroy New York City forever we have
full coverage tonight also uh but first
I want to begin with this I've been
talking a lot about a canary and a coal
mine as it relates to Joe Biden your
president he does not know that tonight
is Thursday but for those of him around
him that do know watch closely because
some of Joe's biggest allies in the
media mob which is nothing other than an
extension of the White House Press Room
they're now starting to turn on the man
that they helped elect remember the
Biden candidate Protection Program and
the presidential Protection Program and
and deny that Hunter's laptop is very
real uh program well we predicted that
when America is overpaid fake news
journalists they really talk show hosts
like me except they're not honest enough
to say so uh uh and I said so by the way
you know they they say they accurately
are covering Biden's massive cognitive
decline in corruption they have up till
now been avoiding it and allegations
that the big guy is in big trouble
buckle up because now even fake news CNN
is starting to tell a little bit of
truth they're beginning to even sound a
little like yours truly take a look
this morning we have brand new CNN
polling the numbers they're looking
rough for President Biden we've been
talking about it all morning and the
fact that it could be a troubling sign
for Democrats and the president's hope
for re-election in 2024. there is no way
to spend this CNN reads the country's
mood right now and finds that America is
deeply unhappy with Joe Biden most
democratic voters hope for a change at
the top of the ticket and Americans
don't take the president and his word
when he talks about his son Hunter Joe
Biden's like that Grandpa that you love
that you believe in you owe a lot but
you you start to wonder uh you know
would you give this Grandpa a high
stress job for six more years or would
you want something else for him 55
percent of Americans a majority believe
Biden's actions related to the hunter
Biden probe inappropriate problematic
new polling numbers out this morning for
President Biden the CNN poll finds his
approval rating sinking to just 39 wow
uh oh that's right Biden is now polling
at 39 percent that's a level that only
Jimmy Carter matched now nearly 60
percent believe that his policies have
now made our economy worse why 61
percent of our fellow Americans live
paycheck to paycheck average American
now owes fifty four thousand dollars in
debt 58 and again a CNN poll uh don't
like Biden personally what's the like
they think he's a bad person and
unlikable a whopping 76 percent are
worried about Biden's ability to even
serve another term justifiably 67
percent of Democrats they wish they
could have someone else other than Biden
leading the ticket and despite Biden's
many many lies over 6 sixty percent of
Voters think that Biden was involved
with his son's business dealings abroad
that brought in tens of billions of
dollars for Hunter and Company with no
experience at all whatsoever they
believe Joe was involved a large
plurality now believed that Joe Biden
actually broke the law on this program
we have long highlighted Joe Biden's
serious misconduct and get this no one
in the media mob has ever really rebuked
our coverage remember very early on I
started to say he was weak and frail in
a cognitive mess yeah I didn't get much
criticism for that and I talked about
Joe milky at night warm milky and sippy
cup and going night night
and if he was really good he'd get some
ice cream before he goes night night
anyway because everybody with eyes to
see knows that it is true but for years
they just simply ignored what was
transparent and obvious to every person
and that is they did this to protect the
big guy and of course obsessively
compulsively hate Trump every second
every minute every hour of every day
every week every month every year now
all of this despite a huge amount of
evidence that Joe Biden committed really
serious crimes then of course we have
the Joe Biden bribery money laundering
allegations now we have photographic
evidence of him meeting with some of
Hunter's business partners having lunch
with some of them Cafe Milano oligarchs
from Russia Kazakhstan elsewhere 20
phone calls that Devin Archer talked
about we've got eyewitness testimony
we've got texts we've got emails that
Joe benefited financially from all this
and a very lengthy paper trail showing
possible money laundering and of course
look at the amount of money we're
talking about not a couple of thousand
dollars we're talking about tens and
tens of millions of dollars funneled to
nine family members of Joe Biden through
Shady shell corporations according to
house oversight committee chair James
Comer Hunter Biden in a sketchy overseas
business deals with China and Russia and
Romania and Kazakhstan and Ukraine and
Mexico and all these other countries all
these foreign business deals were at the
center of it all and yet Joe Biden's
weaponized doj they were ready to sweep
it all right under the rug but now even
fake news CNN they're starting to sound
a lot like this program more and more by
the way I'd like to thank them for
watching but they should give
attribution uh for getting the story
right to us take a look
doj has given me Whiplash on this one
because six weeks ago they were they did
walk into court and they were ready to
get rid of this case for a misdemeanor
and dismiss the gun charge now they're
about to indict him for a felony gun
charge which would likely carry jail
time if there's a conviction the only
conclusion that I think is consistent
with all this is that the whistleblowers
were right that initially doj was ready
to go in there and give this deal away
cheaply and when the political pressure
amped up doj did a complete 180. all
right if you're keeping track CNN is now
essentially admitting that the Joe Biden
bribery money laundering allegation
Scandal is very real though they are
also accusing Joe Biden's Department of
Justice part of his executive branch
they're accusing them of trying to cover
it up to protect the Biden family and of
course they're also heavily suggesting
yeah Joe is way too old and too
cognitively impaired to run for a second
term CNN took one look at their poll and
saw the writing now may be on the wall
they're abandoning ship are they the
first of many that's the question what
prominent elected Democrat will follow
suit what other Democrats will will
follow the example if any Democratic
lawmakers or Governors start openly
questioning Joe Biden's ethics his
family business the millions of dollars
for seemingly no work but for influence
peddling and whether or not bribery and
money laundering are involved if they
start Quest questioning whether or not
he's fit for office his days as a
candidate in the 2024 race they are now
numbered let's be clear here according
to my sources they've already been
trashing Biden behind closed doors no
one in the Democratic party seems to
like Joe Biden they all see what we see
they're just as of now not saying it
publicly and by the way that includes
his vice president Kamala Harris and by
the way she doesn't look mentally
capable herself of doing a good job
everyone knows he's a congenital liar
he's a plagiarizer he's also a
narcissist who would do pretty much
anything for a buck or a little Prestige
and the way that he treated his own
granddaughter in Arkansas not
recognizing this innocent girl for over
four years pretty repulsive and pretty
disgusting she's an innocent young girl
no birthday cards no invites to the
White House and by the way even the
family dog that bit Secret Service
agents got a personalized ornament on
the Joe Biden Christmas tree before this
little girl did Joe Biden the first lady
Dr Jill Biden they have been a National
Disgrace every policy they Implement is
creating more pain for the American
people it's no wonder Joe completed the
doj's transformation into an arm of the
democratic party he knew he'd need that
he doesn't have any character or ethics
and probably couldn't even recite a
single line from our Constitution and
the media mob they know that too and
they've been ignoring it up till now but
that is now beginning to change and the
bad news for Joe Biden well in just a
moment John Solomon has more breaking
news on this family Enterprise as they
say in Fulton County or Syndicate hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else